grazie della possibilità di condividere
con voi questo percorso che stiamo
facendo con tanti altri colleghi ma
anche tanti altri amici e tante altre
realtà come donantonio elena zambon la
libertà in condizione di libertà non è
la stessa cosa che la libertà in
condizione di costruzione
mi piace partire da questa citazione
notissima l'inferno dei viventi non è
qualcosa che sarà se ce n'è uno e quello
che abitiamo tutti i giorni che formiamo
stando insieme due modi ci sono per non
soffrirne
il primo riesce facile a molti accettare
l'inferno e diventarne parte fino al
punto di non vederlo più
il secondo è rischioso ed esige
attenzione e apprendimento continui
cercare e saper riconoscere chi e cosa
in mezzo all'inferno non è inferno e
farlo durare e dargli spazio
se potessimo risvegliare dalle tombe
coloro che hanno lottato per la libertà
della libertà politica
i diritti politici la libertà economica
la possibilità di disporre dei beni per
poter vivere la libertà culturale la
possibilità di studiare di esprimere le
proprie pensieri di leggere e di
informarsi se li potessimo risvegliare
le portassimo qui a milano nel 2015 una
piena 2015 si domanderebbero noi abbiamo
lottato per la libertà della libertà
politica la libertà economica libertà
culturale ci eravamo avevamo pensato che
una volta che queste condizioni fossero
state raggiunte bene gli uomini le donne
del mondo liberi avrebbero creato un
paradiso invece basta guardarsi in giro
diciamo c'è qualche sprazzo qua e là di
paradiso ma c'è molto inferno
allora il tema diciamo di cui brevemente
vorrei parlare stasera è quello della
libertà la libertà nel mondo dei liberi
è in questione
abbiamo un problema con la nostra
libertà e per fare il passaggio in
avanti mi metto sulle spalle di un altro
gigante della storia della libertà
non a caso gli ultimi grandi eroi della
libertà
gli eroi della seconda parte del
ventesimo secolo la libertà sono non
occidentali e l'ultimo certamente è
nelson mandela che proprio nelle
ultimissime righe della sua
autobiografia il lungo cammino della
libertà conclude il suo libro e la sua
riflessione la sua storia con queste
parole la verità è che non siamo ancora
liberi
abbiamo conquistato soltanto la facoltà
il diritto di essere liberi il diritto
di non essere oppressi non abbiamo
compiuto l'ultimo passo del nostro
cammino ma solo il primo su una strada
che sarà ancora più lunga e difficile
perché la libertà non è soltanto
spezzare le proprie catene ma anche
vivere in modo da rispettare a crescere
la libertà degli altri
la fede la nostra fede nella libertà
deve essere ancora approvata
questa è una specie di testamento che un
grande eroe dell'epopea della storia
della libertà ci lascia dicendo che la
libertà che si libera delle sue catene
la libertà che raggiunge i diritti della
democrazia politica e diritti economici
i diritti culturali ha fatto solo il
primo passo verso il suo destino e che
liberi in condizione di libertà devono
domandarsi che cosa ce ne facciamo della
nostra libertà
a me pare
per il mestiere che faccio per la mia
sensibilità per quello che capisco
diciamo che questo è la grande questione
che interpella le società avanzate
potremmo leggere così anche la crisi
finanziaria
dietro la crisi finanziaria la crisi
finanziaria è stato un meccanismo
addirittura mondiale diciamo che ha
moltiplicato è un fattore straordinario
che ha moltiplicato da un lato le
possibilità addirittura estendendole
sull'intero pianeta e dall'altra parte
come dire però nello stesso tempo ha
costruito un grande marchingenio in un
certo senso completamente privo scusate
il gioco di parole di senso che poi
fondamentalmente ci è caduto addosso e
l'uscita dalla crisi
a mio modo di vedere non è semplicemente
anche se per certi aspetti non possiamo
farne a meno non è semplicemente far
ripartire la macchinetta la macchinetta
non ripartirà nel modo in cui funzionato
e dobbiamo come dire rispondere alla
domanda cos'è la prossima crescita già
negli anni settanta si era posta tale
questione
oggi nuovamente la questione cosa vuol
dire crescere
che cos'è la crescita economica la
crescita sociale la testa politica
abbiamo un qualche orizzonte di senso
davanti o dobbiamo semplicemente
limitarsi diciamo così a eseguire quello
che il buon vasco rossi cantava già alla
fine degli anni 70
ognuno perso dietro i fatti suoi cioè il
destino della libertà e l'individualismo
consumerista appunto oppure come dire
destino la libertà può essere da qualche
altra parte
ovviamente essendo diventati liberi non
possiamo aspettarci che ci sia più un
autorità una tradizione qualcuno diciamo
così che non siamo noi che può dirci che
cosa se ne facciamo della nostra libertà
ecco la nostra riflessione ma
soprattutto la nostra amicizia
accompagnamento con i tanti generativi
prova come dire a dare una risposta a
questa questione è lo spunto giusto
perché faccio il professore
universitario in una cella e sulle
formazioni
cito due autori per dire che non ho
messo niente diciamo così è tutto
copiato tra virgolette da una parte sito
erick erickson che il più grande è uno
dei più imprese più importanti psicologi
americani della seconda metà del
ventesimo secolo e dall'altra parte
hannah arendt due autori molto diversi
di culture diverse ma che tutte e due
convergono in maniera originale su un
punto diciamo che la libertà a che fare
non solo col consumare che
fondamentalmente il movimento di
prenderla realtà e mettere dentro ma la
libertà a che fare anche con il generale
cioè quel movimento speculare del
mettere fuori voi in questo momento
state consumando e consumare e bene è
chiaro consumare e bene attraverso il
consumo noi ci arricchiamo ci
arricchiamo di tutto ciò che il mondo ci
può offrire
consumare e bene ma il problema che noi
abbiamo pensato che l'unico movimento
della libertà dovrebbe essere quello del
consumare e come dire continuamente
dovremmo passare la vita a prendere
tutte le possibilità che il mondo ci
offre in qualche modo appropriarsene
e questa è follia la depressione la
bulimia e l'anoressia sono tutti sintomi
di di animi sensibili rispetto movimento
che quando diventa ossessivo è follia ma
non si regge nemmeno più la crescita
economica ma pensate che in italia negli
stati uniti diciamo così solo il consumo
al di là della questione della
distribuzione del reddito e tante altri
temi che qui non tocchiamo pensate che
il prossimo rinascimento economico possa
basarsi sul consumo nostro che resterà
beninteso il consumo una componente
importante delle 1 economia florida ma
pensate che la nostra crescita in futuro
possa essere il consumo individuale
vi sembra realistico certo possiamo fare
consumare un ottantenne come se fosse un
ventenne lo puntiamo un po magari ci
riesce ma è abbastanza
cliccato diciamo così allora il
movimento degenerare il movimento
speculare l'idea è che dobbiamo trovare
un'armonia diversa tra il mettere dentro
il mettere fuori guardate questo cambia
completamente non solo l'idea di libertà
ma anche l'idea di società perché voi se
pensate una società in cui gli uomini le
donne i gruppi e organizzazioni le
associazioni siano messe in condizione
di mettere fuori ciò che di bello
possono portare al mondo cambia tutto in
15 minuti non lo posso dire dimostrare
ma al massimo ci saranno altre occasioni
la l'essere generativi mettere fuori è
fatto come diciamo in questo libretto di
due modi e quattro verdi i due modi non
sono rappresentate ci sono solo le
quattro verbi maledico telegraficamente
due modi sono primo modo un modo
transitivo generare transita dal
soggetto alla realtà esterna transitare
e mettere fuori qualche cosa e
sbilanciarsi perdere il controllo della
situazione
far uscire qualcosa da sé generare a che
fare con la transitività e il secondo
modo è il modo deponente non so chi di
voi ha fatto liceo classico e l'ho fatto
e nei verbi antichi esistono i modi
attivi e modi passivi e poi esistono i
modi deponenti modi del ponente sono una
strana cosa perché sono una forma
passiva un significato attivo da buon
dice da buono studente del liceo
classico non ho mai capito cosa cavolo
fossero stime dei verbi deponente perché
o se è attivo 6 passivo giusto ecco non
mi sarei mai aspettato che allarma i 50
anni avessi potuto scrivere un libro in
cui dicevo che la questione dell'azione
e l'azione deponente che lì in mezzo
l'abbiamo perso anche nella forma
verbale che la de ponent ha a che fare
quella generatività in cui tu sei attivo
ci metti tutta l'energia vitale che ci
puoi mettere ma non pretende di
controllare tutto non pretende di avere
in mano la situazione
sai che la vita che si dispone nel mondo
e ne alla tua esistenza
e comunque più grande di te che c'è un
margine che noi non disponiamo
completamente ecco questa è l'idea di
potenza la generatività a che fare con
la transitabilità e la depone nhtsa e
poi a 4 verbi primo a desiderare
il desiderio è ciò che ci muove dalla
nostra comodità e ci mette in movimento
evidentemente ma non basta a desiderare
il desiderio può essere una mera
fantasia un pensiero fugace un attimo
come dire che non ci porta da nessuna
parte e l'ump è il colpo di fulmine può
essere il colpo di fulmine non al
problema è che dal colpo di fulmine poi
deve passare a una realtà a mettere al
mondo e mettere al mondo momento del
creare è un momento esaltante
a tutti sarà capitato di mettere al
mondo qualcosa o qualcuno
e ci sembra come dire veramente che la
nostra libertà acquisti un senso ma poi
come dire il terzo verbo e prendersi
cura
se non ci prendiamo cura di ciò che
abbiamo messo al mondo ciò che abbiamo
messo al mondo muore e come dice marco
genoa oggi viviamo nella nella mistica
del ricominciamento sembra che tu che la
questione sia solo ricominciare tutto
daccapo e che va benissimo ricominciare
da capo ma qualche volta anche
nascondiamo dietro la mistica aderiscono
del ricominciamento la nostra fatica la
nostra in abilità nel far crescere nel
prendersi cura come direbbe chiara che
oltre a essere mia moglie e la mia
coautrice la cura è un verbo di
reciprocità vuol dire scalda il cuore
cioè mentre ci si prende cura l'altro la
realtà si prende cura di noi lo può dire
credo il nostro don antonio a napoli
mentre ti prendi cura 6 scaldato la tua
vita si scalda e l'ultimo verbo che in
italia è sconosciuto è lasciar andare
perché non sia generativi se non si
lascia andare
che significa nuovamente perdere il
controllo
significa de partorire
per una donna significa passare il
testimone per un uomo significa pensare
che ciò che si è messo al mondo non solo
un figlio beninteso un'associazione un
movimento un'impresa uno studente che è
tirato su quello che aiutato a fare
emergere nella vita a un certo punto
diventi diverso da quello che tu avevi
pensato ma perché questa è la regola
della vita
funziona per fortuna sempre così perché
la vita è più grande di noi desiderare
mettere al mondo prendersi cura lasciare
andare
sono quattro verbi che declinano questa
idea di generatività l'idea è che torno
alla citazione iniziale ci sono già
moltissimi generativi nella realtà
perché è un problema un processo di
maturazione storica una libertà che
rischia di consumarsi su se stessa a cui
non possiamo dare una risposta
moralistica
come dire che ha bisogno come dice
ericsson di superare la sua stagione
adolescenziale per tornare a gustare
questo questa sua capacità di mettere al
mondo e l'italia così come tanti altri
paesi è piena di generativi in questo
sito
genius loci nera e abbiamo già
raccontato una novantina 2 avete già
visti oggi don antonio elena zambon sono
imprese come ad esempio la loccioni che
oltre a fare profitto come una misura
del loro valore fanno qualcos'altro
producono senso bellezza anno gusto
pensano che i loro dipendenti non siano
semplicemente persone da sfruttare ma
siano il vero potenziale il vero
patrimonio che devono valorizzare sono
associazioni terzo settore realtà che
lavorano nei territori come quel caso
pazzesco di pater nello che è un
castello qui nella bresciana un castello
abbandonato che la comunità locale ha
preso in carico ha ristrutturato e ha
reso un luogo di partecipazione sociale
culturale civile in maniera auto
organizzata e poi come di reazioni
politiche azioni politiche naturalmente
nel senso più ampio
come ad esempio la oliver twist a como
che una scuola che è capace di fare ciò
che le nostre scuole non riescono a fare
cioè di rimettere insieme
l'apprendimento del cervello con
l'apprendimento delle mani e voi capite
che e concludo su questa idea che la
generatività è cambiamento innovazione
ma soprattutto per citare hannah arendt
e la pluralità
qual è il destino dei liberi se non
creare le possibilità perché tutti noi
potenzialmente da soli e insieme
possiamo partecipare come dice stiegler
a parigi contribuire alla bellezza del
mondo e qui generativi come dire anno
questo gusto e la cosa consolante che la
realtà sembra andare in questa direzione
grazie